En ce mois de janvier 2017 où il est de bon ton de prendre des résolutions
et bien je me suis dit que pour prendre de bonnes résolutions
il fallait d'abord faire un bilan,
savoir ses faiblesses et ses forces.
Et pour ça 10 chiffres qui m'ont marqué en 2016
ça me paraît pas mal.
Pourcentage, classement... mais pas de fourchette !
Cyrusly ?!
La fraude sociale qui s'élève à 695 millions d'euros
et dont on nous rabâche les oreilles à longueur de temps
en parlant des gens qui fraudent pôle emploi
ou les allocations familiales
ne représentent au total qu'un petit pourcent
de la fraude fiscale en France.
Elle, elle est comprise entre 60 et 80 milliards
2016 a été l'année du scandale des Panama Papers,
je ne vais pas revenir dessus
puisque je l'ai déjà fait dans une vidéo que je vous remets en description
mais ce scandale aura permis de remettre un vrai coup de projecteur
sur l'ampleur du phénomène de l'évasion fiscale.
Alors j'y tiens particulièrement
parce qu'on entend parler toute l'année
du "terrible problème" de la fraude sociale en France
on dépense une énergie folle à dénoncer cette fraude sociale
et à tout faire pour l'éradiquer
quand à coté on entend trop peu parler de la fraude fiscale
Retenez donc bien ce chiffre
il est hyper important
surtout dans ce contexte de crise et d'austérité
j'espère que les candidats à la future présidentielle
visiblement bien motivés par l'idée de faire des milliards d'économies
ont bien noté dans leurs résolutions de 2017 de poursuivre la lutte
Pourquoi "poursuivre" ?
Parce qu'elle a déjà commencé
ça nous amène à notre second chiffre
qui est tombé en mars 2016
C'est le montant total des recettes encaissées grâce à la lutte contre la fraude fiscale pour l'année 2015.
Parce qu'on peut critiquer le mandat de François Hollande sur pas mal de points
mais depuis 2013, avec à la fois le renforcement de l'arsenal législatif
(70 mesures en 4 ans)
et l'amélioration des moyens qui y sont consacrés
on est clairement monté d'un cran en matière de lutte contre la fraude fiscale.
Son montant de recettes constitue lui-aussi un record
12,2 milliards, c'est ouf
et pour vous aider à mettre le chiffre en perspective
c'est plus que les budgets de la culture, de la justice et de l'aide au développement.
C'est le nombre de personnes au RSA en France en 2016
et c'est le 3ème chiffre.
Tout à l'heure je m'indignais de l'énergie dégagée à poursuivre la fraude sociale
avant de s'occuper de la fraude fiscale
et c'est un problème que l'on rencontre pas mal aujourd'hui.
En fait nos médias parlent tellement de certains sujets
qu'on finit par se persuader qu'ils doivent être extrêmement importants.
Et le phénomène se retrouve renforcé par le temps de parole excessif accordé à certains politiciens
aux idées bien arrêtées.
Spéciale dédicace à Florian Philippot ou Eric Ciotti
qui sont pas loin d'être autant à la télévision que Cyril Hanouna.
Lorsqu'on les écoute, on pourrait facilement imaginer qu'un bon quart de la population
bénéficie aujourd'hui du RSA.
Alors qu'en fait, en 2016, c'est uniquement 2,88% de la population qui en bénéficie.
Et notre quatrième chiffre est encore plus révélateur de ce phénomène.
7,5% de la population française se dit musulmane.
Alors jusque là rien de foufou
sauf qu'une étude Ipsos-MORI publiée en décembre 2016
réalisée dans 40 pays et intitulée "Les périls de la perception"
révèle que tous les pays interrogés, hors Indonésie et Turquie,
surestiment leur nombre de musulmans.
La France arrive en tête de ce classement avec une proportion de musulman dans la population estimée à 31%.
31% au lieu de 7,5%.
Je me demande bien ce qui a pu encourager les sondés à imaginer ça !
Et puisqu'on parle de classement et de médias
on arrive à notre cinquième chiffre
Pour le coup c'est plutôt une position, 45ème sur 180 pays dans le classement 2016 sur la liberté de la presse.
Non seulement 45ème c'est pas fou, mais ce qui compte c'est aussi la dynamique.
Et là ça va pas non plus : on a perdu 7 places par rapport à 2015.
Alors à quoi c'est dû ?
A plusieurs facteurs : un attentat contre des journalistes ça fait perdre des points,
des lois mises en place dans la foulée qui ont augmenté les possibilités d'écoute et réduit la liberté d'expression aussi
et l'appropriation de la presse française par une poignée d'hommes d'affaire
dont les intérêts pèsent souvent plus que leur attachement au journalisme.
Parce que, entre les conflits d'intérêt,
une situation financière qui nécessite parfois de faire du sensationnalisme avant de faire de l'information,
on comprend peut-être un peu mieux le classement de la presse française.
Et au passage, c'est pour ça que c'est important de soutenir des émissions comme Cyrusly?!
et comme le projet global autour de la chaîne Cyrus North
et je le dis en toute non-objectivité.
(et le Tipee est en description)
Mais ce classement de la liberté de la presse
n'est pas le seul dans lequel on doit chercher à s'améliorer en 2017.
132 : c'est notre 6e chiffre et c'est aussi notre classement sur 145 pays en matière d'égalité salariale entre hommes et femmes
selon le forum économique mondial
c'est vraiment pas fou
et même si on est classé 15e sur le classement global en matière d'égalité femmes/hommes
c'est incroyable de se dire qu'on puisse être classé en 2016 aussi bas sur un critère comme celui-ci.
35 : c'est notre 7e chiffre, encore une position (c'est mon petit coté kamasutra)
on est 35e sur 37 dans les pays de l'OCDE  (Organisation  coopération développement économiques )  en matière d'inégalités scolaires
dans le classement publié en avril 2016 par l'UNICEF.
Le fossé entre les performances des élèves en fonction de leur milieu social
est très très important en France.
Sur ce critère on est des cancres depuis 16 ans
et un fossé qu'on ne comble pas en 16 ans, c'est un cratère quoi.
Juste pour que vous puissiez y voir un peu plus clair :
le milieu socio-économique explique plus de 20% de la performance obtenue par les élèves de 15 ans,
contre 13% en moyenne dans l'OCDE.
Seuls la Hongrie et le Luxembourg se situent également à un niveau supérieur à 20%.
Après, ce n'est pas une fatalité
les pays qui ont réussi à réduire cette inégalité
ont des profils vraiment variés
ça va du Canada, à l'Estonie, en passant par le Japon...
alors pourquoi pas nous ?
C'est notre huitième chiffre et c'est le pourcentage de croissance moyenne sur ces 4 dernières années
des start-up françaises selon le palmarès de l'OAT de 2016
Et ouais mon gars ! La vieille France !
Ce pays de grévistes dans lequel personne ne travaille jamais sauf entre 2 jours fériés
place 94 start-up sur 500 dans ce palmarès qui classe les start-up européennes
ayant la plus forte croissance de chiffre d'affaire.
Puis au passage, ça nous place à la première place du classement
en tant que pays, puisque le Royaume-Uni n'intègre que 70 start-up à son palmarès
et l'Allemagne 23.
On apporte du positif à cette succession de classements plutôt négatifs,
c'est franchement cool,
et plutôt encourageant quant-à l'avenir économique de notre verte contrée.
En parlant de verte contrée,
il serait intéressant qu'elle le reste
et là-dessus on part tous ensemble découvrir notre...
Notre ?
Oui c'était le neuvième chiffre oui
y a encore quelqu'un qui suit !
c'est le pourcentage d'énergie renouvelable qu'a eu la France sur sa consommation d'énergie en 2015
d'après des chiffres qui ont été publiés en 2016
alors je rappelle qu'on doit atteindre l'objectif de 23% d'ici 2020
on a même perdu 3 places dans le dernier classement
et on est très loin derrière la Suède champion incontesté avec 52,1% d'énergies renouvelables
Alors on se remotive hein
des lois on était votées pour corriger le tir
dont la loi de la transition énergétique
et on rattrape son retard
en acceptant que le nucléaire, bien que fleuron énergétique français
ne monopolise plus tous les investissements du secteur.
Parce que bon, sur le papier, on a tout pour réussir
On est le pays organisateur de la COP 21, on a Nicolas Hulot
Et on a même réussi à faire changer la couleur de nos Macdo !
Et sans transition (énergétique !)
Passons au tout dernier chiffre de cette vidéo, sans aucun doute le plus emblématique de 2016
S'agit-il du chiffre symbolisant la diminution du nombre de mes cheveux
Entre l'avant et l'après été 2016
Non, il s'agit de l'augmentation du nombre d'inscriptions en ligne sur les listes électorales
par rapport aux dernières élections
660 000 personnes se sont inscrites en ligne en 2016
contre 235 000 en 2011
C'est super cool, notamment avec 50% des inscriptions qui ont eu lieu en décembre
Et même si il y a eu des explications avancées par la presse
Je pense entre nous que c'est peut-être grâce à ma dernière vidéo...
Voilà... Je m'avance pas !
Mais j'espère en tout cas que cette vidéo vous a plu
Pour rappel chaque chiffre a sa propre méthode de calcul
son propre contexte
Et tous peuvent être commentés et discutés
Si vous voulez partager le chiffre qui vous a le plus marqué en 2016
N'hésitez pas, la section commentaires est là pour ça
Je vous fait de gros bisous
Je vous souhaite une très bonne année, je l'ai déjà fait mais je le refais
C'est gratuit ça mange pas de pain
C'est pas comme les canards
Love, peace, ciao
Et merci de soutenir le projet ! Merci à tous les Tipeurs
Et ya les réseaux sociaux ! Vous pouvez me retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux
Facebook, Twitter, Snapchat... voilà
Cyrusly les canards ?
Les canards ça m'est venu comme ça, je sais pas..